I know who you are.
You're the attorney whose family they killed.
Not they.
My father.
Put them on.
And now you hunt them.
Adios.
There's proof the cartel helped the terrorists get to the border.
The president's adding drug cartels to the list of terrorist organizations.
You can understand how that will expand our ability to combat them.
We want to see this thing through.
I'm gonna have to get... dirty.
Dirty is exactly why you're here.
You're gonna help us start a war.
With who?
Everyone.
No rules this time.
Your objective was to start a war between the Mexican cartels,
not with the Mexican government.
This girl was witness to the admission, correct?
-Yes, sir.
We can't risk her falling into the wrong hands. Clean the scene.
You want me to cut ties? You gotta get rid of her.
I can't do that.
Don't put me in that situation.
You got to do what you got to do.
I'm gonna need a strike team, two of the Blackhawks, drone from the TAC capability...
Where is the girl?
- Mexico.
You have no reason to trust me.
But trust in me is how you're gonna survive.
Good luck.
- Luck doesn't live on this side of the border.